on the hill today for the giants will be
anthony diesclopani
is 30 years of age in his seventh year
at the big league level this is what he
has done this year nine and three with a
284 era
93 strikeouts against 28 walks in 101
innings
de scala funny sets does not even look
at him in the pitch
swing and a foul tip held by joey bart
and soto has struck out for the second
out of the inning
this pitch appeared to be a slider that
kind of just spun over the inner half
one with the big swing to see the
rotation on that slider john lester in
previous years good success against the
giants
five and one with a two era six starts
so here's wilmer he hit a long home run
last night
3-1 pitch flores takes low ball four he
draws the walk
giants last night in the first inning
were very patient against
espino the national starter it's what
this offense does
so here's yes lester pitches andy rolls
one on the ground a diving attempt by
escobar kicks off his glove
and rolls out into shallow right field
yostremski's gonna be safe at first
flores holds on at second escobar
scrambled to pick it up wilmer was
thinking about trying for third
that's a hit for mikey so here is darren
ruff
one-o pitchy it's a high drive left
field here
going back on the ball parra all the way
to the wall and he'll reach up and drop
it he dropped the ball flores has to
race to third and stop there
the bases are loaded gerardo parr had
just dropped it
so here is solano the giants are the
great opportunity now
bases loaded one out lester pitches
solano lines one into left field and
that's going to be a hit
one hop to para flores will come in to
score yastremski to third he'll have to
stop there one-nothing giants
brandon crawford now high in the air
deep left center way back is para at the
wall
he leaps he's got it
tagging up and scoring yostremski
rough who went halfway goes back to
second lester
pitches estrada swings it's a little
dribbler third base side that's going to
work
ruffle coming to score and absolutely no
chance to make a play
for starlin castro it's three-nothing
giants
and now the wind the one-two swing and a
ground ball
base it through the hole into right
field make that a 13-game hitting streak
for starlin castro
that's a big improvement
the swinging strike three yeah let's
take a look at how low he gets i mean
he's
way down low blocks that little
curveball and then swing through
one and two the couch oh man
you got him to chase that one strike
three that's just
taking advantage of a guy who's
aggressive and who has a reputation to
chase
2-2 that was not a strike that last one
ruff drives this one into the gap
in right center field roble's chasing
he's not gonna get to it one hop
and up against the wall it skips over
the wall darren ruff
with an automatic double he'll be a
second base with nobody out another
extra base hit for darren ruff
lester looks to second now kicks the leg
and throws and crawford lines this one
into center field that's going to be a
hit for brandon ruff coming around third
and he'll get the go sign
from wotus here comes the throw from
robles it's offline and late anyway
darren ruff scores four nothing giants
brandon crawford
gets his second run bat it in 1-0 pitch
he swings and muscles one out into right
center field that's a hit for bart
coming to third solano
hill round third and he's gonna come in
to score
joey bart's two for two that's better
than 500
and it's five nothing giants on the rbi
single by the young giants catcher
strata got an infield hit and an rbi his
first time
well there's another one are you kidding
me
he's done it twice in a row two for two
with two runs batted in on those
little swinging buns and now they that's
ryan harper
the right-hander starts to throw in the
bullpen 2-2
that is muscled over the infield and
that's going to drop for another base
hit
and another rbi here it comes and it's
hit to center field
well hit roble's going back on the
warning track he'll make the catch
tagging from third estrada he'll come in
to score sprinting over to third
austin slater sacrifice fly for
ustremski
eight nothing giants and that's gonna be
all
for john lester so this is game number
six on the road trip and for the fifth
time
in six games a national starter unable
to
complete five innings and today unable
to complete
three innings two and two pitch
swing and a miss and the bat flies out
of the hands of
josh bell and goes hurtling its way down
to the first base coaches box bouncing
in through the coach's box right to the
feet
of first base coach randy norm
3-2 struck him out swinging with a great
slider
veteran giants players not many have had
better run producing seasons
by the all-star break then brandon
crawford
57 rbis now he smokes that one to right
center field
roble's chasing he'll play it on a
bounce knock it down and rolls away
and who's going to pick it up finally
soto will a little fight for the
baseball out there crawford
with a double roble is a centerfielder
soto the right field
i mean this is just split in the gap but
it goes hard around first base with
anticipation if there's a bobble i want
to be in position to take the extra bag
and it's exactly what happened and for
crawford
he very easily put himself in scoring
position
the 2-2 bart swings and misses at a
fastball so all the curve balls and
harper able to sneak a fast ball by him
to get his first strikeout now the
one-two
breaking ball swinging a miss to the
slow curve diesel
fatty is struck out second strikeout for
ryan harper
austin slater one for three against john
lester he'll stay in the game
and face the righty harper swinging
there's a shot deep down the left-hand
line
hit really hard way back there and it
bounces right at the base of the wall
para over the field to karam and he
fires into second and
slater is in with a double and the 2-2
breaking ball in there strength recall
the 72 mile an hour curve ball
third strikeout for harper no runs
wanted to walk in two men left for the
giants
and at the end of five innings it's san
francisco eight and washington nothing
kind of an old soul in the batter's box
that's soto
he had a two-strike approach at age 19.
strike three called on the outside he
didn't think so
east govani strikes him out for the
second time that's his six strikeout
that's a first called strike three
to right field ustremski hustles in
looks like he'll have a play yes he does
what a catch mike yastrenski
more great giants defense well on a play
that you couldn't make before
because the mounds were there now you
got an open lane
and just a beautiful job of ballpark
awareness
they get the out they nothing giants
here's crawford
putting on a show in this series
crawford to center field
robles still going back roblace looks up
gone brandon crawford
home run number 18 422
feet and he's got three legs in the
cycle he needs a triple
how many times have you seen crawford
take on center field with the long ball
speedy the big right-hander 28 years of
age will face gerardo parra
here's the 3-2 swinging a line drive
shot to left that'll be a base hit the
other way
and a lead-off single for parra in the
top of the seventh
i mean tony tony gwen could just serve a
ball to left field at the
kind of just what power did yeah that's
just like that i'll cedi's escobar
trying to get the nats on the scoreboard
for the 1-0
escobar hits a drive to right center
well hit chasing back yastrimsky on the
go
dives can't get it it's by him and
rolling toward triples alley this will
clear the bases
para scores pereira scores escobar
racing for third he's in there
standing with a triple he has walked the
bases loaded to start off the inning
center field bay's head the ruff will
come in to score
tyro estrada who got a four hit game
half a day kid
three rbis here's jackson reitz
how about that first major league hit in
his first at-bat
and it's gonna be extra bases for the
young man from hickman nebraska
josh harrison enter the game back in a
double switch
harrison pulls it deep short a play at
second
and josh beats it out now jackson reets
gets to touch home plate for the first
time is a big leaguer
still two outs in the ninth inning
spinning the pitch turner hits one to
right
yastremski back on it still going back
reaches up and makes a catch
and gently collides with the pillar in
between the second and third archways
and the giants
finish off the nationals by the final
score of 10-4 an 8-nothing lead after
three
and the giants just kind of cruised from
there
10-4 final three wins in a row for the
giants they've taken the first two games
of this series against the nats